>> Sandra: DEMOCRATS IN
VIRGINIA FEELING VERY UNEASY
WITH LESS THAN 24 HOURS TO GO
UNTIL THE POLLS OPEN AND THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
SURVEYS SHOW GLENN YOUNGKIN
SURGING AGAINST
TERRY McAULIFFE LEADING THE
DEMOCRATS TO SCRAMBLE TO CHANGE
THE MESSAGE.
THEY SAY IT'S NOT ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AFTER MAKING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT A KEY PIECE OF
THIS CAMPAIGN.
>> WEARS DONALD TRUMP?
'S PLEDGED ALLEGIANCE TO HIM SIX
TIMES?
WHY ISN'T HE HERE?
>> THIS IS ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE IN VIRGINIA AND
NOT ABOUT TRUMP, IT'S ABOUT
WHO'S GOING TO TAKE THE NEXT
LEVEL AND GET US THROUGH THIS
COVID CRISIS.
>> Sandra: ALSO TRYING TO
CONVINCE VOTERS THEY CAN BE
TRUSTED DESPITE FOUR OF HIS FIVE
CHILDREN TO PRIVATE SCHOOL.
>> WE HAVE A GREAT SCHOOL SYSTEM
IN VIRGINIA, WE HAVE RAISED
THEIR FIVE CHILDREN, OF COURSE
PARENTS ARE INVOLVED IN IT.
>> Sandra: ARE COMMENTS LIKE
THAT GOING TO HURT HIM?
>> Jesse: AND IS NOT JUST
ABOUT HURTING HIMSELF, BECAUSE
HE HAS BUT FLIP-FLOPPING AND
BACKTRACKING, SHOWS HIM LOSING
THE MOMENTUM.
THIS IS THE TALL, HANDSOME GUY
WITH GOOD HAIR.
IT IS GOT A GOOD DELIVERY AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY, DOESN'T HAVE A
SLOPPY MOUTH THAT THE MEDIA CAN
TAKE AND USE AGAINST HIM BUT
HE'S ALSO GOT THIS, NICE VEST
AND THIS WORKS FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS.
A RED FLEECE VEST AND NOW BECOME
WHO HE IS AND EVERY SINGLE DAY,
YOU KNOW IT WHEN YOU SEE IT AND
THAT WORKS IN VIRGINIA.
DOESN'T WORK EVERYWHERE, BUT
THAT VEST IN VIRGINIA MEANS YOU
ARE PROFESSIONAL BUT IT ALSO
MEANS YOU'RE CASUAL, MEAN ZERO
FAMILY GUY AND THIS GUY HAS NOW
SHOWN THAT HE CAN BE ALL OF
THESE THINGS TO ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE.
THIS EDUCATION ISSUE WHICH IS SO
BRILLIANT WHICH IS A DEMOCRAT
ISSUE AND NOW HE IS PROVIDED
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATS AGAINST
THE ESTABLISHMENT AND ALSO
SOFTENS HIS IMAGE BECAUSE IT
MAKES THEM LOOK LIKE A CARETAKER
FOR YOUNG CHILDREN AND ALSO
NEUTRALIZED RACE.
I AM NOT FOR SEGREGATION.
IT PSYCHOLOGICAL SEGREGATION.
TERRY IS FOR SEGREGATION, I'M
FOR BRINGING BACK
MARTIN LUTHER KING'S VISION OF A
COLOR-BLIND SOCIETY.
THAT IS AN EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE.
>> Greg: SHE DIDN'T MEAN THAT.
>> Jesse: IT'S INTERESTING.
>> Sandra: ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS, CLAIMING THIS IS NOT
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP, HOW CAN HE
SAY THAT WHEN HE IS INVOKED HIS
NAME SO MANY TIMES.
>> Katie: HE'S REALIZED THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT ON THE
BALLOT.
IT WITH THE HEALTH OF THE MEDIA
HAVE USED TRUMP AS A WAY TO
SCARE PEOPLE AND IN VIRGINIA IN
PARTICULAR, GLENN YOUNGKIN IS
NOT JUST RUNNING ON EDUCATION
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
TERRY McAULIFFE SHOT HIMSELF
IN THE FOOT ON DURING THAT
DEBATE, LIMITING THE STATE
GROCERY TAX AND GOING THROUGH
THE ROOF, BEEN CAMPAIGNING ON
WANTING TO REPEAL THE STATE GAS
TAX TO PEOPLE HAVE MONEY IN
THEIR POCKET.
BROUGHT EVERYBODY UNDER THE SUN,
HAS REALLY MADE IT ABOUT PEOPLE
IN VIRGINIA AND MADE IT LESS
POLITICAL WHEREAS
TERRY McAULIFFE IS A POLITICAL
MACHINE BACKED BY THE CLINTONS
AND THAT'S WHY HE IS GETTING
SUPPORT FROM PEOPLE OF ALL KINDS
OF BACKGROUNDS.
>> Sandra: BELMAR HAS THIS
MORNING FOR VIRGINIA DEMOCRATS.
>> HE WAS THE GOVERNOR, HE IS
NECK AND NECK BECAUSE THE ISSUE
BECAME -- I SAID THIS MONTHS AND
MONTHS AGO THAT THE ISSUE IN THE
COMING ELECTIONS IS GOING TO BE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE SCHOOLS.
PARENTS ABOUT AND THEY DON'T
LIKE WHAT'S GOING ON SO THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY ARE LOSING
CONTROL.
>> Greg: THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
I'M GLAD HE WATCHES MY SHOW.
WE CANNOT FORGET ONE OF THE
BIGGEST STORIES IN VIRGINIA WAS
THE UNSTABLE SCUM BUCKETS OF THE
LINCOLN PROJECT TO TRY TO
EXPLOIT RACIAL CONFLICT BY
CREATING A HOAX.
AND THE FACT THAT RACE HAS
BECOME THE PRISM THAT THE MEDIA
AND DEMOCRATS OFTEN DECIDE TO
SEE EVERYTHING THROUGH AND NO
CONCERN FOR HER CHILDREN,
COLUMNISTS AND PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA CLAIM THAT WHEN PEOPLE SAY
YOU'RE A CONCERNED PARENT, THEY
REALLY MEAN CONCERNED WHITE
PARENT SO NOW PARENTING IS BEING
SEEN THROUGH THIS RACIAL PRISM
BY PEOPLE WHO SEND THEIR KIDS TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL BECAUSE IF YOU
WENT BY THEIR LOGIC THEN IF YOU
SEND YOUR KIDS TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS, YOU ARE CONCERNED
PARENT ERGO WHITE PARENT, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
BUT THIS HOAX THING MIGHT BE
THAT TURNING POINT WHERE THE
DEMS HAVE TO CONSIDER LETTING GO
OF THIS RACIAL PRISM AND CHANGE
THE TOOLS AND START OPERATING ON
A DIFFERENT MANNER THAN THEY ARE
NOW.
>> Harold: THERE'S A LOT
THERE.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
EDUCATION ISSUE, THERE'S NO
DOUBT YOU WOULD NOT HAVE
IMAGINED THREE MONTHS AGO AND
NUMBER OF FACTORS AND A LOT OF
THEM HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE.
MY KIDS HAPPEN TO BE
BLACK-AND-WHITE AND I CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THEM AND WHAT THE
SCHOOLS TO PERFORM WELL.
I KNOW GREG MEANT THAT AS WELL.
BUT IN THIS RACE HERE, TWO
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE LEARNED.
GLENN YOUNGKIN WINS, THIS IS THE
PLAYBOOK TO WIN THE MIDTERMS AND
AT THE PLAYBOOK OR HOW YOU
CAPITALIZE AND TRY TO SHUN THE
PARTS THAT DON'T DO IT.
I WOULD REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
REPUBLICANS WOULD BE IN A
MAJORITY IN THE SENATE HAD
DONALD TRUMP NOT DIVIDED
REPUBLICANS IN GEORGIA.
TWO, IF TERRY WINS, IT'S A
MESSAGE FROM DEMOCRATS THAT A
MODERATE DOWN THE MIDDLE
ECONOMIC MESSAGE.
VIRGINIA HAS BEEN THE NUMBER ONE
STATE BUT NOW BASED ON TAXES AND
EDUCATION, LIVABILITY, TERRY WAS
GOVERNOR FIVE YEARS AGO.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE TO GET BACK TO TALKING
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, BACK TO
TALKING ABOUT UNDERSTANDING YOUR
PARENTS ARE AND IT'S EDUCATION.
THIS WOULD BE PROBABLY